he's at the oval for probably the
principle of the lunches i mean they're
going to be these big lunches everywhere
and for the prince to get a chance to
have a chat with everybody the food
looks pretty interesting there i don't
know that you know necessarily that's
all the most hearty good things to eat
but that's not the point of a party as
you just have everything you possibly
can and i think they're going to move
the prince around people elsewhere
obviously some particularly good music
lined up for him and he'll get the
chance along with the duchess of
cornwall to meet people who've had a lot
to do with the community around the area
there and just want to come and take
part yeah
i was saying joanna earlier that we're
expecting something like 200 000
individual big jubilee lunches lots of
bunting we're told
12 million people um joining in and the
big lunch.com has said be careful how
you dispose of that i'm sure prince
william would appreciate that you can
recycle your bunting they've made the
calculation 48 million pennants probably
will be used today so you can either go
onto their website and figure out how to
dispose of that appropriately or they
say even better keep it till next year
and make it an annual event which is a
good idea that's brilliant just bring
out the bunting
i went to a community center the other
day and they were making bunting out of
old curtains and potato bags that had
union flags on and they also have this
special party donation center there
where they have anything that's for
parties they can give it out to families
who can't afford to to get their own
bits and pieces for parties which is
lovely and that's what they'll continue
to do after this these jubilee lunches
also all of the food has been donated so
there's there's ways of doing it kind of
on a bit of a shoestring yes
do you remember we always used to make
our own christmas decorations we always
made things out of paper paper you could
paper chains
taking his tea with him
eat lunch this is the thing with the
prince of wales whenever you're on tour
with him and the team around him always
say it's a nightmare he doesn't stop for
lunch so i don't think he'll probably be
eating anything but he's got his cup of
tea there hasn't he i don't know if we
can eavesdrop in as he's having a chat
let's see
marvelous
okay so that's what they're having for
their big lunch not got my glasses on if
anybody else is
i think sometimes people are terrified
of eating when they're in the presence
of royalty because you can suddenly be
asked a question your mouth is full or
like a woman once at windsor castle at
one of the great
parties there um had just taken a
sausage and bitten it and she saw the
queen and prince philip coming towards
her so she put the sausage behind her
back
monster on me did the whole interview
with the queen with a sausage behind her
she was terribly conscious of that
i can always eat i'm like a labrador if
you put food in front of me
exactly
exactly that um
somebody needs to come around with the
bottle right now yes i think there's
some glasses
here yeah oh you think we're
replenishing you think they've started
already i think yes
maybe hit midday and yeah
and the big cake you were telling us
about here yes so this is the a big
jubilee lunch cake and as you were
saying this is probably
kind of the
flagship jubilee lunch because of course
we have at the end of the throne and and
his wife
charles and camilla it has to be said on
on thursday they did sort of a bit of an
impromptu walk about they've walked from
buckingham palace back to clarence house
and they are in their element when they
are with people they again for their
security team it could be a bit of a
nightmare they see a crowd and they
immediately make a beeline for it and
look you can see he's having a lovely
chat there and also i'm always really
envious of members of the public because
they get to ask all the questions that
we don't so that lady there saying how's
your weekend going you having a lovely
time that was a wonderful speech we had
the back of his head so we couldn't hear
what he was replying but uh yeah i'm
sure the answer is yes he's having a
fantastic time he looks like yesterday
yeah
yeah did you see um the little ones were
out last night so they were they went
all the way to wales didn't they cardiff
with their parents and then we're back
again and they were as good as girls i
thought i thought good as gold
and i think occasionally you have to be
nudged you know wave your flag now
because it's automatic with some of us
either older people or very young people
you don't automatically wave the flag